Isaiah Berlin famously said to
understand is to perceive patterns so
it's a moment in which the dots connect
and a new Gestalt is revealed right it's
a moment where you bump up a level and
you see the big picture people describe
these moments as epiphanies right at
their best they can be ontological
awakening they can be forceful reckoning
with what is an unseen world can come
into view an evanescent lightning-bolt
of meaning in the perceivers mind can
make you go it's an exhilarating neuro
storm of intense intellectual pleasure
the very act of creativity is a kind of
ecstasy it's a kind of exorcism it's a
kind of shaking off and passing through
of energy the feelings and revelations
and visions they come through us but not
from us and though they are with us they
belong not to us we become vessels
right as it passes through us we become
conduits for message for a trans mission
we find ourselves seeded with
information and from this we have no
choice but to respond
we contend right artists contend with
the unknown and then they make it
no they tile it with language a mark the
map they leave the paper trail they show
the way come back to the village right
for people to marvel then at what we've
brought back the souvenirs the art which
serves as a mattes through which the
transcendent can shine through even
people perhaps not educated in art
history people untrained to see the
nuance in great art can still find
themselves jolted from truth even if
they don't fully understand it we
respond to the ecstatic vision whether
or not we can discern its meaning this
is the nature of art this is the nature
[Music]